good morning John it's Friday on
Wednesday I asked Twitter to pick
between three different video topics and
boy where there are a lot of people who
didn't want to hear about any of them
but one of the tweets to get the most
likes was this one how about D puppy so
this video is entitled top 10 best dogs
ever if you are unsatisfied with this
content and Glenda Steffi or any of the
31 people who liked her tweet including
me let's begin number one stubby a dog
who served the Allies in World War one
after being exposed to chemical weapons
and then recovering in a hospital sudden
became attuned to the scent of these
chemical weapons and could alert
soldiers before they could smell the gas
coming he was wounded twice he served in
17 different battles and he captured a
German spy recognizing him by his
language an act for which a stubby was
promoted to sergeant outranking his own
number two Lily a pit bull who poked her
unconscious owner off of the railroad
tracks because there was a freight train
coming the owner did not get a hit by
the train Lily did poor puppy lost one
of her legs but survived and if using
that story is remarkable check out
number three dog trying to cross a
highway gets hit by a car
second another dog this hero dog drags
the dog that has been hit by the car off
of the road like wanders out into the
interstate pulls the dog off I'm not
showing you the video because it's
pretty graphic and terrifying but I
don't know why is this dog doing this
it's a I mean I guess just because I
supposed to cry today speaking of dogs
rescuing people and there are so many
wonderful stories of dogs rescuing
people we have this cat who is clearly a
cat but is nonetheless a very good dog
I'm revived in the 1950s some Russian
scientists went out onto the streets of
Moscow to collect stray dogs thinking
these dogs they're obviously used to
extreme circumstances they tested and
trained these dogs and one of them lekha
was sent into space and became the first
animal ever to orbit Earth also the
first animal ever to die in orbit around
the earth not how we wanted that one to
end you know the first animal that went
to space fruit fly number six Alvin and
the Chipmunks I know you think I'm crazy
but it's a little-known fact
actors who played Alvin the Chipmunks
and Alvin the Chipmunks the Squeakquel
actually very small dogs nope number set
summer and Lazarus who are two dogs but
we're just calling them one sorry these
dogs didn't just survive mid eighteen
hundreds Anne Francisco we're stray dogs
outnumbered people and were killed and
poisoned regularly they became
nationally famous for their
companionship with each other and their
ability to kill rats like crazy summer
and Lazarus were eventually exempted
from local laws and they showed up all
the time in cartoons about San Francisco
they just sort of be there in the
background number eight this dog which
somebody sent me on to ask people to be
dogs on Twitter so picks one real cute
good dog number nine Tweety Bird who is
a canary and Canaries are birds but they
are named after the canary islands and
the canary islands are named after the
Latin word for dog so by the transitive
property Tweety Bird is a dog Oh number
10 my dog lemon who passed away this
year and as we all know the vast dog is
your dog and there's nothing wrong with
that hey I understand why a lot of
people wanted me to talk about puppies
today it seems like we're in a much more
tense moment than we were a couple of
years ago and it does seem like that's
going to get worse before it gets better
we're being asked to pay attention to a
lot of different big things all at the
same time way that were fed content
about what's going on in the world right
now is inefficient and it's overwhelming
and it's manipulative too frequently now
the people who are tasked with trying to
inform the public are trying to win
rather than trying to inform and that is
something that I'm getting super sick of
but there are still good dogs and there
are still good people and in the coming
years we can't choose between taking
care of ourselves and taking care of our
world's problems we have to do both of
those things John I'll see you on
Tuesday